hello everyone welcome back to the
Capablanca saga we are here at Tsang
Peterburg and it's 1913 we said that we
are going to go straight to a 1914
tournament of son Peter Berg but I
decided to show you this game and maybe
another one from 1913 so it wouldn't
appear as if kappa blanka was only going
doing negotiations from 19 and 11 cents
Sebastiaan tournament up until at the
1914 tournaments of son peter berg and
here is the first time host cool roll
kappa blanka faces well his future rival
Alexander Alexander hid him
now this is the Sabourin Cup and they
invited two Capablanca to come to Russia
they said that they prepared a nice
exhibition for him where kappa blanka
will face three very strong Russian
chess masters here young alexandra yeah
in the capablanca is about 25 years here
of age and ideation would be around 2021
but he's already a very strong player in
in the hamburg tournament of 1910 he
defeated several eater talk over and the
drew against Frank James Marshall and
then calls but he defeated dr. Emil and
Widmer who you all know drew who tied
with Akiva Rubinstein in the 1911 census
Bastian tournament so already a very
strong player but he still has to make a
name for himself basically here they are
using him to test the the Russian
masters against Jose raúl capablanca
which is something the Russian did quite
often and here Capablanca would face
three chess masters again alexandra
snezhko-blotskaya
field or even reduce to the meter ski
and of course alexander alexander a
chilean and for capablanca to win the
sovereign cup he has to win all three
matches he will play two games against
eleven two games against Moscow borovsky
and two games against Ducati mirskiy and
if he wins all of all three matches then
Capablanca will be the winner and if he
doesn't then the one who has the best
score against Capablanca is the winner
of the cup that's what that was the idea
of this Cup but it's basically an
exhibition showing of couple Blancas
prowess and the Capablanca had a few
other exhibitions he he played a lot of
games during the negotiations with
Lasker and this is what one such game
and it's a really nice game I'm sure
you'll enjoy it as I think would become
to known as one of the magician's of
this era but for now he still kind of
struggles in simple positions where
Capablanca thrives so let's see this
game kappa blanka has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have d5 c4 c6 we
have the Slav defense evaluation III and
Knight to f6 and with the Knight to f3
and east sex we transpose into the
Queens gambit declined and okay we have
Knight B to D to Knight B to d7
violation and now Bishop to d3 and this
is a one of the cases where the knight
is developed on D to wear black doesn't
really gain anything by forcing White's
to lose a tempo here even though the
bishop was already developed because
after white captures with the night
you're not gonna be able to kick away
the night to a bad square because now
the e5 square is available for White's
night as the knight on f3 also covers
that so after Bishop to d3 we have
Bishop to e7
bialyan and now we have castles we have
castles by yeah and now comes Queen to
c2 and here okay couple Lanka develops
the Queen they're still the obvious
problem what to do with the dark square
bishop in White's camp but and of course
you're pressuring the h7 pawn so here
color has to make a choice we're still
pretty much in the opening phase of the
game either he will go h6 to remove this
pawn as a future target or he will go b6
b7 go rook c8 prepare c5 and so on but I
didn't goes for a different plan but
before we show you what I had in mind
we will first check out this very nice
photo it's a photo of it was taken in
1913 I don't know if it's this exact
game or or wherever but it is the first
game Ali and Capablanca ever played and
I don't think they ever played another
game in 1913 since this game was played
in December maybe it stretched the
supporting Cup may be stretched to
January but I believe this is a photo
from from this event so let's just enjoy
it there we have young
Jungian whoo we said it some five years
younger than Capablanca definitely one
of one of those greatest photos in chess
history it's also available in color you
can just google kappa blanka I'll even
color you will easily find it so also a
very nice image but getting back to our
game like we said h6 a possibility b6
another possibility Kylian goes for D
captures on c4 and we already mentioned
this isn't the the best way to go about
this couple on Knopf captures with the
night taking further control of the e5
square and we have c5 okay a lien has a
different plan we have Knight c2h5 and
now C character son d 4e capture son d4
and nights to b6 and the eye nathan has
a precise plan he isolated a couple
Blancas pawn on d4 it he now once it
wants to make it a target he wants to
block it with his knight he wants to
play Knight to d5 develop the Bishop of
Bishop d7 maybe sees c6 get the door
open to the game and then simply
continue but Capablanca shows him that
this is far too slow and that that h6 or
b6 plan was was the way to go here
Capablanca goes Knight to g5 and what's
Kappa Blancas idea here the night was
the only piece that was defending the d4
pawn so it's actually a very nice trap
if if either hand were to capture on d4
or even just try and kick away the night
kylekhan loses the game so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
it's actually a force making three to
make it easier for you but a very nice
idea I'll give you a couple of seconds
as usual for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you have just
defeated Alexander again and for those
of you who just won't enjoyed show
Bishop h7 check and now you will either
capture and face Queen captures on h7
checkmate or you will move the King for
example here and then you get Knight
captures rook has the capture no other
options and Knight captures is checkmate
the bishop is covering g8 and also the
Queen is still protecting the bishop on
h7 so this is the idea idea he now has
the force back the night with g6 it's
not forcing back the night but the night
no longer has any purpose here
now there are some there are some lines
were night captures on h7 can be played
but Capablanca decides it's there
there's no point in doing this so he
simply goes back Knight it comes to f3
and now you might think why did couple
Blanca go to g5 because couple Blanca
saw that Ali Evan would have to play g6
and then he would just have to go back
so did he really gain anything he just
lost two moves with the night but he has
look at all the weak dark squares around
the black King now he created a weakness
so now the night is back on f3
protecting the pawn on d4 and now this
Bishop can be very nicely developed on
h6 so alien blocks at King g7 we have
Bishop to g5 developing the bishop also
connecting rooks and now the Queen will
come to d2 to support the bishops
advance to h6 we have Knight B to d5 -
finally achieves his plan of
centralizing this night even though it
took him really a lot of time rook 8 2
c1 kappa blanka now takes full control
of the C file we have Bishop to d7 and
now comes Queen to d2 the control and
the C file is not all that great as
after rook comes to c8 the bishop is
also helping out with with this and also
black has a firm grasp on the c8 squares
so first Queen to d2 threatening Bishop
h6 to window rook on f8 we have Knights
to g8 and this is what kappa blanka
accomplished when kappa blanka played
this Queen to d2 move
of course couple Lanka never thought
that he would play Bishop to h6 but he
was expecting Knight to the g8 and he
wants to trade the dark square bishop
sand you might think from blacks
perspective
yes White's dark square bishop is an
excellent attacking piece so I
definitely want to get rid of it but
Capablanca sees more here Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Bishop
the e4 and here you can see that
capablanca has removed the dark square
Bishop from the game he has a knight on
e5 which is a dark square so that Knight
will not be able to be threatened with
the dark square bishop you could only
attack it via the Knights and the
Knights will need some time to to
counter this Knights effects on e5 and
even that even then if you do get one
night to attack it used to
the knight on f3 guarding it which can
always recapture on e5 and the other
thing but could do is push f6 but then I
mean capablanca just said okay if you
play f6 you're weakening your King even
further I'm just gonna beat you then so
here we have Bishop to b5 attacking a
couple Blancas rook rook moves to e1 and
now comes Queen to d6 and Capablanca
eliminates one of the Knights
so Bishop captures on d5 as long as a
couple of Lanka eliminates this night
and this Knight isn't really doing
anything then couple Blancas knight on
e5 is a monster night so e captures on
d5 you cannot capture with the Queen
because rook c5 wins the bishop here so
after this we have it captures on d5 and
now capablanca is better he's better in
development he his pieces are better
both of his rooks are occupying the only
to open files on the board but if I
lacking if only he can somehow play rook
a c8 this rook rudder left Rock f2 e 8
and activate this Knight then black will
surely equalize and couple Blanc of
course doesn't want that
so first Queen to a5 using the fact that
the bishop on b5 is undefended
Capablanca transfers his queen the c7
without losing losing time with a6
defending the bishop and now comes Queen
to c7 here capablanca offers a trade of
Queens which can't really be avoided if
you move the Queen somewhere then the
Queen to b6 can be played then the
Brooke can come to c7 and the white will
just have a better position so Allison
decides to trade Queens Queen captures
we have rook captures and here's another
problem for Aliyah now you cannot defend
the b7 pawn if you try and defend it
let's say rook a b8 or the other rope
comes to be it which doesn't really make
much sense as you would lose control of
the f7 point Knight g5 and now you no
longer can defend your f7 pawn the two
Knights are attacking at the rook is
spinning at also attacking it play
something like marriage 6 and then
simply night II 6 check wins the game
the pawn is pinned you cannot capture
you lose the rook on f8
black is just falling apart here so
after rook to c7 with h6 alien figures
that it's of the utmost importance to
take take away the g5 Square from
White's night
and now rook captures on b7 Capablanca
grabs a pawn and slowly but surely he's
making progress rook a to c8 ok a lien
is now down upon but he takes control of
of the C file and rook to c2 is aliens
next move that's the without question we
have b3 kappa blanka prepares now a4
after a forest played the bishop has to
move and then the rook from b7 will also
be protecting the b3 pawn so by doing
this couple blanca takes care of the
Queen side we have rook to c2 by taking
but there isn't a better move here
really and we have a 4 attacking the
bishop here alien has two options he can
either go something like brush up to 8
which gives further protection to the f7
pawn but then comes knight d3 as you can
see the rook is completely covering the
Queen side night is coming to c5 the a6
pawn will fall and on the other hand
black doesn't really have any good moves
this rook hasn't any potential to
threaten anything the bishop is pretty
much stuck there the rook is stuck there
the night can't really do all that much
and the d5 square is you know free for
grabs for any of whites Knights if
needed black and just by well of course
first you will make some room for the
King so you don't get checkmated but
after that you know it's just a
free-for-all
so after this a4 move I even said ok I
can't go below ba that's pointless he
went Bishop to e2 but Bishop to e2 also
not well it's it's a move but it doesn't
work here kappa blanka immediately finds
the best move and hones down on the
biggest weakness in alia hints camp
he plays Knight to h4 and here is the
problem the biggest threat here now is
Knight captures than g6 the King of
course cannot capture the other night
discovering g6 as well and the pawn will
not be able to recapture as of course
the pawn is pinned so how do you prevent
this you could go King f6 one of the
possibilities but then you just have a
king and f6 you still can't move your
look it's pretty much stuck guarding the
f7 pawn white will simply start pushing
the pawns and that King is a goner and
you still have pretty much
nothing to do here on the other hand
after this night to h4 move you could
protect it with Bishop h5 yes you do
protected but then g4 traps the bishop
not not to the greatest option so really
not much and you know you don't really
have any squares for this Bishop but ok
night which for was played and here a
lien decides to play a bit more active
as he's really out of options here
she plays h5 allows Capablanca to grab
the g6 pond to make some room for the
king
we have Knight H captures on g6 now
comes Luke to e 8 getting rooked out of
the way but now - also loses the f7
point I didn't thought of everything so
he didn't make room for his King on h6
we have King to h6 and now comes f4 and
still black is just down so much
material he's down three pawns and still
without without any serious counter play
we have a five limiting the movement of
couple uncle's pawns on the Queen side
and now comes Knight back to h4 and here
it's it's really a problem you don't
have a good way of preventing Knight f5
checkmate the King is stuck on h6
you can't go Bishop d3 the knight can
capture it and end up while capturing it
for example if here Knight captures
guards the real Connie want so you
cannot capture the rook either so not a
problem here you know without any any
better ideas Ian decided to capture the
knight on e5 with F captures on e5 and
now comes King to g5 I'll even starts
well not running away with the king so
much but rather start using the King as
an attacking piece we have g3 defending
the knight here and now comes King to g4
again he has to hope for something but
it doesn't work once again I asked you
to pause the video again a couple Monica
has a force checkmate in three and it's
a very nice idea
you know don't move until you see it as
they would say so I'll give you a couple
of seconds or as much as you want since
you can pause the video for for those of
you that were able to do it really
congratulations you're an excellent
checkmater in three and it's not
simple of an idea and for those you who
just wanna enjoy the show Luke g7 check
I know it's not much of a puzzle we all
hate puzzles that start with check but
for this game it is as it is King h3 and
it was in this position that Capablanca
play tonight's the g2 and Alexander
alien resigned to the game why did he
resign well we once again returned to to
the core of this game which is which are
the dark squares Capablanca eliminated
well forced awaken to eliminate
capablanca dark square bishop and then
capablanca gave his own light square
bishop for one of the knights so the
Knights cannot counter the effects of a
cup of Blancas Knights here
Knight to f4 is the threat of checkmate
and there is no move that can even
prolong the game as f4 is a dark square
either hand still has only a light
square bishop you can't do anything with
the rook that there are no moves that
help you can't move the King so nothing
you can do here helps whatever move you
make let's say h4 Knight f4 is checkmate
after Knight G - yeah Alexander they can
resign the game and I wonderful victory
for Hosur roll kappa blanka and it's an
important victory as two of them are you
know will become great lifelong rivals
so history will always remember that
josé raúl capablanca has a won the first
game they they played and maybe also the
second but if you're interested we can
also show the second one as it's also
from this event it's from the souring
cup a cup of monk I had to play against
each of them two games so we can also
show that one and I think I will before
we go to Sun Peterburg 1914 tournament
we're gonna show the other game against
Arjen as well and then we're gonna talk
a bit more about the results Capablanca
achieved here sir that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank raffle Grishka Alfredo sandrini
jvr account Christian karate and the
Kenneth McKay of Scotland for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content
we're definitely continuing the
Capablanca saga but you know
whenever an interesting suggestion pops
up I will of course check it out and
present that game as well so thank you
and I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your Saturday